il fait station qui se voulait pacifique
les sapeurs pompiers de côte-d'or venait
porter leurs revendications à paris la
fin du cortège a tourné autrement on se
dirige donc vers nos bus pour pouvoir
partir puisque façon c'était la fin la
fin de la manifestation
on est parqué sur sur la place de la
nation les gendarmes mobiles sont à une
centaine de mètres toutes les rues
donnant sur la place sont à menacer
alterné crs ou gendarmes mobiles crs et
gendarmes mobiles
deux minutes après c'est les canons à
eau qui arrive et ça commence à
dégénérer et de là ils envoient une j'ai
pas combien de deux bombes lacrymogènes
et de truqueur anti encerclement lors de
la dispersion un de ses collègues lé
pompier blessé
il voit une grenade dans teasé
encerclement là qui éclate en l'air et
le il a peu le temps de retourner la
tête il se prend une un éclat ou une
bille dans son casque
voilà là il va perdre à new york il a
rien demandé rien du tout et ça nous
fait chier je leur en veux pas
spécialement à eux j'en veux aux
ministres tutelle qu'a donné cet ordre
et c'est le même que le nôtre donc on le
prend comme une trahison le prends comme
une non reconnaissance des sapeurs
pompiers
le pompier blessé ou va être prise en
charge par la brigade de paris puis
hospitalisé un coup dur pour les
pompiers de côte-d'or
c'est comme quand on voit au feu voilà
et qu'on revient sans un bonhomme et ben
là c'était pareil on est monté à 80 on
est parti à 79 je vais vous dire que on
a dit qu'on est dans le bus on ne
faisait pas les malins et hélas tout ce
qu'on a là nous dans le département
c'est une présidente qui n'appelle pas
le colonel qui prend même pas de
nouvelles de lui franchement les
maîtrises en place plus tôt
pour l'heure le pompier blessé demeure
toujours hospitalisé à paris il a été
opéré hier sous réserve d'avis médical
il ne devrait pas perdre son oeil mais
selon ses collègues syndicalistes sa
blessure demeure très grave